it was slamming things shouting
belittling name-calling this is a story
about allegations of domestic abuse
having things
thrown at you
there's been one point where I've
actually had to go and hide in a room
from him domestic abuse that escalated
over the course of a marriage then
there's been kind of peppered throughout
sexual abuse and sexual violence he
would make
flippant remarks about household objects
making a good murder weapon and in her
case the alleged abuser is a serving
police officer for two years his Force
has refused to investigate him her words
are spoken by an actor it's been an
uphill battle to even
have them take anything seriously it
makes you feel worthless and when you've
come from a or been removed from that
sort of relationship it kind of
reinforces that feeling of
my words don't matter and if anything I
wouldn't feel safe calling 999 because I
wouldn't trust
given what's happened that they would
even bother
coming
at all
after being contacted by Sky News West
Yorkshire police said it couldn't
discuss the case in detail adding we
encourage anyone who's a victim of
domestic abuse to contact us allegations
are taken seriously including
allegations involving West Yorkshire
police officers and staff and will
always be fully investigated a West
Yorkshire police officer has been
suspended as part of the inquiry and the
matter has been referred to the
independent office for police conduct
it was this video of the arrest of
police officer David Carrick later
convicted of dozens of offenses against
women that prompted her to speak out at
the end of the day a police perpetrator
they are actually the most dangerous
type of perpetrators and it's a scary
place to be where
you feel like nobody's on
the other side of the phones to come and
help you
and it's
it's
petrifying after the crimes of David
Carrick were revealed the National
Police Chiefs Council ordered forces to
identify any allegations or intelligence
about officers that needed further
investigation all these forces saying
they're taking it seriously but they're
actually not
and I'm a prime example of in the
current climate they're not taking it
seriously at all for her and for so many
it will be actions that speak louder
than words Greg Milam Sky News